I think I'm nervous to find out I'm like
not who I think I am I'm expecting to
learn what kind of what I am today we're
doing a 23andme test to find out if we
actually are who we think we are we've
been wanting to do this for a long time
now we've actually patented about and
submitted the steps of 23andme a long
time ago before they reached out to even
sponsor this video my family's like
really mix my dad's white but then my
mom is born in India but also of like
Welsh descent I think sometimes we just
call myself a mutt don't know much about
my ancestry I know that I went to scroll
and once my dad would like get our
family tartan and I was like were
Scottish the name 23 me comes from the
fact that human DNA is organized into 23
pairs of chromosomes their DNA analysis
was created to help you understand your
own DNA and find out which parts of the
world your ancestors are from about your
health your physical traits and more the
first thing we have to do is collect our
spit so that we can mail it 23 meetings
whoa the process requires collecting two
milliliters of your own saliva and that
means that 23andme which has over 1
million participants of the company has
collected over 2,000 liters of slava
which is disgusting but all the kind of
Awesome we're gonna do Greg results
right now whoa
I'm 99.99% here here rank point a
presenter in French and German why they
group those guys I'm 1.4 percent
Scandinavian it is not shocking to me at
all so you're right for British he most
likely had a fourth great grandparent
who is 100% yet cook without ya good
Iberian okay so I'm like 99.9% British
0.1% Siberian I'm gonna get a Siberian
Husky
off of that one yeah coot person who
made it into my lineage in 1732 okay
yours is lit up all around the globe of
my friend
whoa and there's Indian there okay good
I haven't been long to everyone wait so
I still am quite European of which 32%
is British 5.3 percent Chinese
you believe Korean not playing like
curtains I'm not sure if it's right to
be so excited about like having like a
percentage point Korea me it's just cuz
I love Korean food and cultures so much
it feels really cool to and have a
little bit more of a definitive answer
of my background I have 190 Neanderthal
variants you look like I'm an adult to
me oh yeah baby they're so big and
beastly this is more than 69% of 23 me
customers oh well so a lot of money
Italian Durr thought that explains a lot
I'm dirty like that maybe where you're
like pain resistance comes from that is
well information I want you to look at
your genetic information is told from
our DNA using snips which are relatively
common variations in DNA base pairs the
saliva is broken into fragments and laid
over a snip chip or a credit card sized
plate covered in DNA probe analyzing
these chips gives light into your
ancestral background as well as fun
questions like can you smell asparagus
in your urine or are you prone to male
pattern baldness blinders you are like
to go out later but it is like being
your mostly light beige and then have
side and moderate at a pair and then
very great Impala Wow
so your skin is fair hence the burning
hence you need to wear lunch you are
very susceptible to mid knowledge are
what we're at least good you can smell
up there yeah I can develop their
asparagus for sure and I didn't even
know people couldn't both American IO
used to think it was that some people
had smelly asparagus pee but it's like
just based on hookahs yeah everyone had
and it says I'm likely a sprinter slash
power muscle Taurus boom it's a run and
sperm when I was a kid but what not I
think everyone did well I have like a
bad knees bad back iris printer cost
power muscle type Cooper I'm not a
sprinter it's you know perhaps a pass I
I never talk this is Bo I'm Helen motion
on this oh yeah I'll call flush reaction
unlikely to flush okay so that is not
true I drink I literally turn
it's not the case maybe not cool when
you're partying with your friends to be
turning purple and everyone be like are
you okay or like I'm just right not fun
you know sometimes you feel like an
imposter in your body when you're a bit
of like a mixed child you kind of don't
know like where it's belong and but but
knowing that that is the truth I'm like
oh I don't have to like belong to one
specific ethnicity that excites me I
love traveling I love being engaged with
other cultures and ethnicities so it's
like it's just an excuse to do that more
and be like oh it's in my blood like I
need to go experience all these other
things now we want to thank 23andme for
sponsoring this episode if you'd like to
get your own kit you can head to 23andme
dot-com flash ASAP we'll put the links
in the description and you'll be helping
to support our show as well so we had so
much fun doing this you can do it to
even find out about your ancestry but
also your wellness and health we're
about to go leave and look at ours
really details thanks again for watching
and make sure you subscribe for more
episodes of the lab and we will see you
next time
[Music]